bó bộ với chung bộ tiếp tục có khả năng xu tiện dung ngày nặng.
Sống ngày nặng có khả năng cao hơn sau với chung mình yong năm.
Còn ngày phòng nặng kê khách của bộ có nơi đặc biệt kê khách tại các khu vực này.
Báo, át thông dịch nơi hoạt động chung khu vực biển đông,
vài hừng chực tiếp đến rất liền Việt Nam,
ở mức tương đương sau với chung mình yong năm.
Chung mình yong năm chung khu vực biển đông là một phẩy sau kênh
và đầu bộ với rất liền Việt Nam là không phải chíng cơn.
Đây cập đến tình hình mưa, chung tâm sự bà khi tự thủy văn của xa nhận định trong thời gian giữ báo.
Mơ lần sẽ giọng sẽ tập chung chủ yếu tại khu vực bộ bộ và tất cả tình thủ thình hoa đến hả tính.
Khu vực các nguyên chung bộ và năng bộ xuất hiện nhồng ngày có mưa sau và có giâm.
Có ngày có mưa bờ đến mưa tò, thời gian mưa tập chung và chiều và đêm.
Tổng lượng mưa trên cả nước phẩy biển sắp 4 sau với chung miền yong năm.
Dên mắt bộ và khu vực tự thình hoa đến hả tính.
Còn nơi cao hơn từ mấy lâm đến bác mấy phần chăm sói chung miền yong năm cùng thời gian.
Chí nó liền hoạt động của gài hội tụi dịch đời và sống 1 tình năm ở phía Nam.
Có thể gây ra các đường mưa sau và sống, mưa kêu xảy giả khi những tự thủy tin nguy hiểm như lóc sét mưa đả và sống dịch.
Tại các khu vực bộ và chung bộ khi những tự năng năng năng năng ngầy gà đình hộn đáng kể đến nổi sống và sả sất của gây dân.
Các hiện tự nguy hiểm khác như tâm lóc sét mưa đả và sống sức mạnh.
Có khai năng suy hiện trên phạm bi cạnh hước, tập trung mêu hông ở bác bộ, tự thân quà đến hả tính con mình trung bộ và nằm bộ.